stress for many of us it's just a way of
life but what steps can you take to ease
that stress and live your best life
kelly is here from wellness by kelly to
talk meditation welcome back thank you
for having me again i always feel such a
calm when you are around you just have
that way and i really believe it's you
know you're probably living your best
life because of some of these these tips
and tricks and meditation is a key part
right meditation is a key part and i
will tell you in the past in my former
life i was a stress case and that was a
big part of what led to all of my
hormonal imbalance i think that a lot of
people don't really recognize that
chronic stress over time can lead to a
variety of really unwanted symptoms in
your physical body so how do we do it so
many of us are like yes i'm stressed and
yes i want to meditate but i don't know
how to meditate my my brain won't stop
but what what kind of advice do you give
to people like me and others out there
so my first piece of advice is that the
thoughts are actually supposed to be
there the point of meditation is not to
stop the thoughts it's actually to
become aware of the thoughts i think
that we all have a million thoughts
going at once right and so when we can
become more aware of the thoughts that
are repeating in our head the ones that
are causing us stress that are causing
us anxiety then we can actually make a
shift and do something about them so
when we sit in a place of quiet it's
really important to start to become
aware of the thought so know that you're
not crazy if you're having the thoughts
the other thing is to really try a bunch
of different types of meditation there's
guided meditation there's mantra
meditation there's music there's breath
work there's so many things so if one
type doesn't work for you try something
else is there a type that you really
find resonates with you so on my
platform i do guided meditations where i
will guide my members through a
meditation get them into a state of
relaxation and then get them to become
aware of those thoughts that we're
talking about and to me that is really
really helpful because it's someone
sitting there like telling you exactly
how to relax your body with some
peaceful relaxing music in the
background can you give me a 10 second
version of your guided meditation yes
okay 15 seconds so go ahead and ground
your palms onto your knees close down
your eyes
take a nice slow deep breath in through
your nose
exhale out through your mouth let go of
anything
that came before this anything that's
going to come after this
and just ground yourself right right now
noticing your thoughts
noticing what's coming up for you
and not in judgment but in curiosity
take a deep breath in
blink those eyes open
wow and just notice how one grounding
breath you feel a sense of calm come
over you just with one grounding breath
i did feel that it was like a wave i'm
not gonna look i mean i am serious that
was just it's just so many times that we
just don't take that time and really
that was what 15 seconds that you did
and oh my goodness if people want more
information or maybe they'd like to try
one of your meditations how do we do
that you can actually try all of my
guided meditations with my seven day
free trial at wellnessbykelly.com
and workouts and recipes are all on
there due to it so that you can start
feeling like the best version of
yourself from the inside and it really
helps with your focus and your mood you
always have a smile on clarity i think
we can all be happy like kelly so yeah
so for more information visit
wellnessbykelly.comwellnessbykelly.com
great stuff thank you so much thank you